[Música]
sabemos de dónde vienen los alimentos
y conocemos realmente los recursos el
esfuerzo que hay que realizar para que
todos los días en nuestras mesas podamos
comer sabemos que se necesita suelo que
se necesita agua que se necesitan
nutrientes que hay un esfuerzo humano
muy importante detrás de esa producción
de alimentos que tenemos que llevarlos
desde donde se producen hasta donde se
consumen somos conscientes realmente de
todo lo que hay detrás de un alimento
cuando al final llega a nuestra mesa
sinceramente creo que no creo que cada
vez estamos más lejos de la forma en la
que se producen los alimentos y siempre
me gusta poner dos ejemplos de ellos en
primer lugar cuando a un niño le pedimos
que nos dibuje un pollo normalmente qué
es lo que nos dibuja un pollo sin plumas
tal y como lo ve en el supermercado en
la carnicería muchos de nuestros niños
ya no han visto una planta de dónde sale
un tomate un olivo dónde sale una
aceituna o una granja de donde salen los
alimentos o los animales que nos comemos
pero esto que para un niño bueno pues
puede que no nos sorprenda pero yo
muchas veces cuando oigo hablar a las
personas de alimentación me da la
sensación de que ellos van al
supermercado cogen cada vez pues un kilo
de arroz un kilo de azúcar una botella
de aceite y se creen que automáticamente
ese producto que hemos cogido de la
estantería se repone hay alguien detrás
que lo está produciendo y lo vuelve a
colocar en la estantería y la próxima
vez que vayamos va a volver a estar
lleno sin embargo bueno
todo eso yo creo que es un proceso y es
consecuencia de un cambio y es que hasta
hace 100 años teníamos muy estábamos muy
próximos del campo vivíamos mucho más en
las zonas rurales sabíamos cómo era la
agricultura poco a poco nos hemos
convertido ciudadanos y ese vínculo con
el campo lo hemos ido perdiendo entonces
yo creo que es bueno que en cierta forma
sigamos manteniendo esa relación porque
eso nos permitirá bueno pues valorar más
lo que tenemos y quizás también pues
cuidar más de nuestro nuestro medio
ambiente a vosotros algunos de vosotros
os ha preocupado alguna vez el que no
seamos capaces de producir todos los
alimentos que necesita el planeta
yo creo que todos somos conscientes de
que cada vez somos más de que cada vez
por suerte comemos más y que cada vez
hay menos tierras para poder producir y
eso pues algún en algún momento puede
que nos encontremos con una situación
complicada de que no haya alimento o que
no seamos capaces de producir alimentos
para todos y eso que a nivel particular
yo creo que hay muy pocos que realmente
estemos preocupados a nivel de los
grandes países si existe una gran
preocupación y yo creo que bueno eso
hace que cada uno busque una medida unas
determinadas acciones para intentar
resolver esos problemas no solo voy a
poner dos ejemplos me voy a los dos
países más grandes china en china viven
el 20 por ciento de la población mundial
sin embargo sólo dispone del 9 por
ciento de las tierras bueno para un
gobernante chino una de sus mayores
preocupaciones es cómo alimentar a más
de 1000 millones de personas y bueno lo
están intentando resolver por distintas
vías por un lado pues intentan invertir
en tecnologías que ayuden a que seamos
más productivos y por otro lado pues
están intentando comprar tierras en
cualquier
del mundo para poder luego trasladar
esos alimentos hasta china claro
lógicamente lo de la compra de tierras
en otros en otros países pues puedes
resolver el problema de china pero no
resuelve el problema del resto de los
países el otro caso donde también la
alimentación es una de las grandes
preocupaciones del gobierno es los eeuu
el país más poderoso del mundo pues
bueno dentro de las líneas que su
gobierno tiene marcadas como
estratégicas como vitales para su futuro
es potenciar esos desarrollos
tecnológicos que nos ayuden a producir
cada vez más alimentos y dentro de una
de las agencias federales que tiene el
gobierno americano como es el fbi la
segunda tarea más importante que tiene
encomendadas el fbi es asegurar que todo
el esfuerzo que hagan las empresas
americanas por generar nuevas
tecnologías pues al final se quede en
empresa americana y que y que pueda ser
bueno rentable para que puedan seguir
invirtiendo es la segunda la primera
sabéis cuál es la lucha contra el
terrorismo yo creo que eso un poco nos
da idea
de la importancia que en este país se le
da a esa cuestión pero bueno esta
cuestión de la preocupación por la
alimentación tampoco es algo nuevo de
ahora y me gustaría hacer un pequeño
recorrido histórico si saltamos 10.000
años
y todo lo que ha tenido que ver con la
alimentación al final ha supuesto
grandes desarrollos tecnológicos que en
un principio surgen para mejorar nuestra
alimentación pero que luego se extienden
al conjunto de la sociedad e incluso
cambios sociales importantes que han
venido motivados por esos desarrollos
tecnológicos en la alimentación el
primer gran desarrollo tecnológico fue
hace 10 mil años
sabéis cuánta población había en la
tierra hace diez mil años sólo cinco
millones de personas que prácticamente
estaban por todo el planeta hasta
entonces el hombre pues nos dedicamos
nos dedicábamos sobre todo a cazar y a
recolectar y no íbamos desplazando
conforme íbamos esquilmando conforme se
iba reduciendo la disponibilidad de
alimentos en un territorio pues íbamos a
otro a otro territorio para poder seguir
comiendo pero hace 10.000 años ya había
problemas para poder encontrar alimentos
para 5 millones de personas y hubo el
primer gran desarrollo tecnológico fue
que tuvimos que pasar de ser
cazadores-recolectores a ser
agricultores tuvimos que empezar a
cultivar la tierra para poder
asegurarnos
el suministro de alimentos hubo un
cambio social también importantísimo en
esa época el hombre pasamos de ser
nómadas a empezar a sentarnos en los
territorios teníamos que cultivar la
tierra y teníamos que esperar a que esa
tierra nos diese los frutos que de los
cuales no íbamos a alimentar surgen los
primeros núcleos de población que poco a
poco van creciendo y que se
transformarían en lo que hoy son las
grandes ciudades bueno vamos a dar un
gran salto en la historia de hace diez
mil años pasamos bueno a finales del
siglo 18 imagino que todos sabéis
habréis oído hablar de malthus y bueno y
de la alerta que lanzan porque a finales
del siglo 18 pensaban que la población
crecía muchísimo más rápido que la
producción de alimentos y que no íbamos
a ser capaces de alimentarnos todos y
seguíamos con esa progresión a finales
del siglo 18 había 800 millones de
personas sobre la tierra
prácticamente coincidiendo en el tiempo
unos pocos años después tuvo un
desarrollo tecnológico que ha sido
fundamental para el desarrollo de la
agricultura con posterioridad no fue
algo que es bueno que puso en marcha un
científico francés que se llamaba
vilmorin y que consistió en la mejora
genética vegetal es decir es trabajar
con las plantas para intentar que esas
plantas puede incrementarse en sus
rendimientos de manera considerable el
trabajo fundamentalmente con la
remolacha y en muy pocos años consiguió
incrementar multiplicar los rendimientos
de azúcar que tenía la remolacha por 15
imaginaros el salto tan importante que
supuso multiplicar por 15 la capacidad
de producir alimentos en un determinado
espacio y bueno ya por no alargarme
mucho más me aproximó al siglo 20
mediados del siglo 20 ahí también hay un
salto cuantitativo y cualitativo en la
producción de alimentos que fue que ha
sido espectacular y que ha sido lo que
nos ha permitido avanzar durante todo
durante todos estos años lo que se
conoció se conoce como la revolución
verde
y sobre todo pues actuó en 13 líneas que
han sido muy importantes por un lado es
el desarrollo de lo que se llaman las
semillas híbridas por lo que para los
que no conozcáis mucho no estáis muy
familiarizados con la mejora genética
con la agricultura las semillas híbridas
consiste en que en una determinada
variedad tú eliges dos individuos
intentas quedarse con lo bueno de uno y
con lo bueno de otros y el hijo de esos
dos que tiene lo bueno de los dos al
final es el que utiliza para poder
seguir reproduciendo esa variedad la
segunda gran avance tecnológico que hubo
con la revolución verde fue la
mecanización empezamos a utilizar las
máquinas todo el desarrollo que había
habido con la revolución industrial pues
lo trasladamos al campo y empezamos a
utilizar las máquinas para trabajar en
la agricultura eso supuso pues que
éramos mucho más eficientes que podíamos
trabajar en condiciones mucho más duras
y que necesitábamos menos personas
también para poder producir muchos más
alimentos y la tercera cuestión fue
bueno es un poco el desarrollo de los
agroquímicos
a utilizar fertilizantes que permitían
que las plantas creciesen muchísimo más
rápido empezamos a utilizar
fitosanitarios que permitían luchar
contra las plagas que hasta entonces
pues habían mermado muchísimo los
rendimientos de los cultivos esta
revolución verde nos permitió pasar de
2500 millones de personas que vivían en
la tierra a mediados del siglo 20 a
7.500 millones que vivimos en la
actualidad pero no sólo es ese salto en
la capacidad de producir alimentos como
digo también tiene consecuencias sobre
el resto de la sociedad vosotros os
imagináis qué sería de nosotros si
todavía tuviésemos que dedicarnos como
pasaba a principios del siglo 20 la
mitad de la población a producir
alimentos si no se hubiese producido esa
mecanización sí sí sí sí eso sí la mitad
de los que estamos aquí tuviésemos que
estar trabajando en la agricultura para
poder asegurar los alimentos para todos
qué es lo que es lo que pasaría con
nuestra sociedad
pues no lo sé pero yo me imagino que
tendríamos menos smartphone que
tendríamos menos ordenadores que
tendríamos menos coches porque habría
menos gente disponible para producir
esos productos y serían muchísimos más
caros entonces seguro que muchos de los
que estamos aquí estaríamos ahora mismo
trabajando en el campo para poder
producir los alimentos que necesitamos y
bueno y ahora llegamos a la situación
actual
aproximadamente vivimos 7500 millones de
personas en el planeta tierra para el
2050 se espera que seamos 10 mil
millones de personas vamos a ser capaces
de alimentar a 10 mil millones de
personas dentro de poco más de 30 años
yo soy optimista y creo que sí
y creo que sí y por varios motivos si os
voy a intentar explicar con cinco líneas
que creo que pueden ser muy importantes
para asegurarnos esa alimentación dentro
de unos 30 años en primer lugar lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es tirar
menos alimentos ahora mismo un tercio de
los alimentos que producimos en el
planeta lo que estamos tirando y por qué
los tiramos pues por distintas
circunstancias en algunos casos es
porque no nos gustan como son
físicamente vamos a un sitio encontramos
una masa manzana perfecta redonda
brillante y nos encontramos al lado una
manzana deforme y al final cual cogemos
por la perfecta y la otra termina pues
bueno creo que no la introducimos en
nuestra cadena alimentaria en otros
casos perdemos muchos alimentos porque a
lo mejor no tenemos las condiciones
adecuadas para poder almacenarlo y para
poder transportarlos y eso a lo mejor en
los países desarrollados ocurre menos
pero en los países menos desarrollados
por desgracia ocurre con bastante
frecuencia precisamente a lo mejor donde
más alimentos faltan
y el tercer elemento por el que por el
que tiramos muchos alimentos es porque
nos gusta cuidar muy bien a nuestro cubo
de la basura y muchas veces tiramos
alimentos que a lo mejor están casi que
en perfectas condiciones para poder
consumirlos pero porque se ha pasado la
fecha de caducidad por cualquier otro
motivo terminan en el cubo de la basura
yo creo que esto es un poco consecuencia
de que lo alimenta al final casi que son
demasiado baratos y de hecho cuando en
los peores años de la crisis bueno se
decían que la estadística de la basura
que generábamos se había reducido
enormemente porque teníamos muchísimo
cuidado en lo que tirábamos bueno pues
primero tenemos que tirar menos
alimentos en segundo lugar tenemos que
mejorar la formación de los agricultores
y tenemos que asegurar que toda la
tecnología disponible pues llega a
cuantas más partes del planeta mejor
para darnos una cifra en europa para
producir un kilo de trigo necesitamos un
metro cuadrado de tierra en áfrica la
producción es por cada metro cuadrado se
producen 100 gramos de trigo si fuésemos
capaces de trasladarle a los
agricultores africanos todo lo que
nosotros sabemos todas las tecnologías
que nosotros disponemos pues a lo mejor
no llegarían a un kilo pero podrían
llegar a 500 gramos eso sería
incrementar de manera muy importante los
alimentos que producimos el tercer
factor es el agua yo creo que el factor
más estratégico que hay para producir
alimentos es poder disponer de agua ahí
en las zonas del planeta donde hay agua
no hay problema para producir alimento
hay muchas zonas donde no hay suficiente
agua y tenemos que ver cómo podemos
bueno crear agua o poder hacer llegar
agua a esas zonas áridas en las que se
podrían transformar en auténticos
vergeles
si pusiésemos del agua
la biotecnología el desarrollo de la
biotecnología al final la biotecnología
lo que no ha permitido al hombre es
conocer cómo se desarrolla la vida y a
partir de ese conocimiento hemos
intentado ayudar a que las plantas los
animales pues sean cada vez más
productivos que sean capaces de aguantar
situaciones de estrés como pueden ser
malas o altas temperaturas o bajas
temperaturas o sobre los alumnos o como
pueden defenderse mejor contra las
plagas todo ese desarrollo
biotecnológico ha sido una parte del
éxito que hemos tenido en incrementar la
producción de alimento y va a ser
fundamental de cara al futuro y el
último elemento que bueno que es una
tendencia que cada vez está más visible
en los países desarrollados es que
tenemos que comer más vegetales y menos
animales al final las producciones de
animales son poco eficientes en el uso
de los recursos por poneros en un
ejemplo en el sector ganadero más
eficiente es el porcino para producir un
kilo de carne de cerdo necesitamos 3
kilos de carne de vegetales
cereales al final hay una tendencia a ir
sustituyendo progresivamente productos
animales por productos vegetal y eso
pues está permitiendo o nos requiere que
desarrollamos otro tipo de cultivos con
alto contenido en proteínas como pueden
ser las leguminosas la quinoa el cable
etc bueno y todo esto que os cuento
teóricamente es muy fácil ponerlo por
escrito o contarlo en una charla es muy
fácil de decir pero es fácil de hacer es
fácil de que estas cinco grandes avances
que pueden ayudarnos a resolver parte de
los problemas de la alimentación del
mundo se pueden hacer pues yo creo que
sí y además tenemos la suerte de estar
en una tierra donde hemos sido capaces
de hacer el mayor cambio que ha sido que
ha realizado el hombre en cuanto al
desarrollo de un territorio y a la
producción de alimentos en apenas 50
años hemos sido capaz de transformar un
desierto donde no vivía nadie donde la
gente para poder buscarse la vida tenía
que emigrar a otros territorios y de ahí
hemos pasado a ser un vergel no somos
capaces de producir los alimentos las
hortalizas que consumen 500 millones de
personas durante nueve años
europa depende de las hortalizas que
somos capaces de producir en almería
hemos pasado en ese territorio donde
antes era un desierto de vivir 3.000
personas a vivir 300 mil personas yo
creo que es un claro ejemplo de todo lo
que he estado comentando antes y que
podría ayudar a que para el 2050 no
tengamos problemas para poder
alimentarnos eso no obliga a hacer algo
y yo creo que tenemos un gran
si hemos sido capaces de hacer esto en
nuestro territorio porque no tenemos la
generosidad de trasladar todo ese saber
hacer para que en otras partes del
planeta en otras zonas donde bueno pues
mejor las condiciones son similares a
las que nosotros teníamos hace 50 años
de pobreza de situación de séptica
porque no somos capaces de transformar
esa realidad le haremos un favor a ello
y al final nos haremos un favor a todos
como habitantes de este planeta
[Aplausos]
[Música]